[Music]
you'll know when I'm dating someone
let's just put it that way it looks like
Priyanka Chopra and Nick Jonas just took
their relationship to a whole new level
[Music]
the pair was spotted rocking matching
rings okay okay so they aren't wearing
gold bands on that finger but they are
identical the Quantico star was
photographed sporting the new bling on
her right ring finger while Nick has
been wearing it on his right middle
finger 25 year-old singer also were the
accessory on stage at the MTV Movie and
TV Awards last month the two first
sparked romance rumors when they arrived
at the Met Ball in New York City
together in 2017 we were both wearing
Ralph Lauren we were on the same table
we were in the same hotel we decided to
go together and it was just one of those
since then Priyanka and Nick have been
seen out and about together a lot they
even spent the fourth of July with
Nick's older brother Joe Jonas and his
fiancee sophie Turner last month a
source told et that Nick had also met
Priyanka's family the source dished
quote they're inseparable they're
spending a lot of time together and are
really enjoying each other's company
[Music]
[Applause]